Usually when people talk about auditing, the more is always better.
The more auditing you can do--other than the cost of it--
the more you have a likelihood of catching cheating.
But in this case, that's not the case. We have to be careful.
If we audited all the outputs of the mix net,
well then I would reveal exactly what the permutation was.
We have a tradeoff here between voter anonymity and catching cheating of the mixes.
If we just audited one output, the chances of catching cheating would be too low.
If there are N votes and mix net can chew on half of them,
we then be one half probability of getting caught.
This is much too low. It's probably not necessary to cheat on half the votes.
The last step can see what the actual votes are and decide which ones to cheat on.
Cheating on a much smaller fashion than one half and getting caught with the much
less probability than one half would make that risk worthwhile in many situations.